any survey internet user is familiar
with Godwin's law which states that as
an online discussion progresses it
becomes inevitable that someone will be
compared to Hitler and if you don't
believe me you're worse than Hitler
well now Twitter Stefan heck watch your
language is coined a brand new law even
more relevant for our horny modern world
brazzers law if you're unfamiliar with
browsers it's the wildly popular point
site that you've just pretended to be
unfamiliar with so comedians what is
browser's law what is it Paul Tompkins
browsers law comes on after Rizzoli and
Isles right what there's a guy using a
ladyboy
[Applause]
thank you okay all right
other people have answers too Jessica
yeah it's when God closes a he
opens a back door
[Applause]
[Laughter]
Kurt Braunohler I'll always be surprised
to find out I have a smaller dick than I
thought I did yes boy very good but
you're all wrong
browsers law states that anybody who
tweets at a major news network has also
recently tweeted at a pornstar porous on
play this Trump supporter tweets at CNN
they did just fine a hashtag fake news
hashtag crap News Network and then
literally one minute later he tweets at
porn star Sarah J tits
[Applause]